hello I'm capela show product manager
for Club memory store cloud memory store
is Google cloud platforms in memory data
store service the beta release of cloud
memory store supports Redis which as I
know is one of the most popular in
memory data stores available today
getting started with cloud memory store
is easy once you go to the Google Cloud
console go to the menu and if you scroll
down under storage you will see the
memory store option if you click on the
memory store option it'll take you to
the memory store landing page if you are
creating memory store for the first time
the Google Cloud console will
automatically enable the API for you in
this particular case I have created a
few instances already but let's go ahead
and create a new instance to create a
new instance click on create instance
button once you click on create instance
button it will take you to the create
instance page the first thing that you
need to provide is the instance ID which
uniquely identifies the instance that
you're provisioning once you provided
the instance ID you can optionally also
provide a display name which is a more
descriptive name for the instance when
you provision a cloud memories for
instance we provision Redis version 3.2
behind the scenes we ensure that all the
critical patches are applied so that you
don't have to worry about whether there
are any security vulnerabilities that
you need to worry about the next thing
you need to choose is the service tier
cloud memory store provides two tiers of
service basic and standard the basic
tier provides a standalone instance of
Redis and it this Stier is great for
simple caches the standard tier provides
a highly available Redis instance with a
highly available available Redis
instance you get both a master and a
replica once you select the tier select
the region but called memory store you
can only connect to the instances within
the same region so if you choose your
central one applications with the US
central one can connect to that
particular instance once you choose a
region you can either choose a
particular zone
we're the master instance we'll be
deployed or you can choose any if you
choose any we automatically pick the
zone for the master and the replica
instance the next thing you want to
select is instance capacity or the size
of the Redis instance memory source
allows you to choose anywhere between 1
and 300 gigabytes and depending on the
size as you can see the instance will
provide different network throughput for
the 300 gigabytes you can see that
you'll get about 1,500 megabytes per
second and for one gig one gigabyte you
get about 375 megabytes per second once
you've selected the right size for your
application the next thing you need to
select is the network or the VPC network
where the instance is going to get
deployed the VPC network determines
which VMS can connect to the instance
once you've selected the network we can
also choose the eviction policy if you
choose to change it from the default in
this case I'm going to select all keys
LRU and then you go to and click create
once you click create you can see that
the instance is getting provisioned but
before I tell you how to connect to the
instance I just want to quickly touch
upon how easy it is to scale a deployed
instance now if you want to change the
size of a deployed instance you click on
the instance and click on the edit
button once you go into the Edit Page
all you need to do is change the size of
the instance if you want to change one
GB to 5 GB just change the size and
click Save and we automatically scaled
instance for you one thing to note here
is that the basic tier when you scale a
basic tier of tier instance we fully
flush the cache and also the application
gets disconnected but in standard tier
the scaling is mostly at all an
operation where you'll lose connectivity
for a brief period and there may be a
little bit of data loss because of
unreplicated data so as you can see it
is very easy to create and scale a Redis
instance using memory store now let's
take a look at how we can connect to the
memory store instance as you can see
when we deploy the memories for instance
we deploy using a
private IP address this is great because
the your reticent sense is automatically
protected from the Internet
because it can only be connected using a
private IP cloud memory server is also
fully read as protocol compatible so you
can actually progress benchmark against
it and let's see how it goes as you can
see when you run the benchmark you get
pretty good throughput with the cloud
memory store instance that you've
deployed so the next obvious question is
how do I monitor the instance to monitor
the instance there are different
multiple ways to do it if you go into
the details of an instance in cloud
console there are a few metrics that we
have published that you can use to
monitor the instance but we have more
detailed monitoring available in
stackdriver
and with the stack driver integration a
lot more of the metrics are available
through the stack driver dashboard as
you can see if you go into stack driver
you can see all the key metrics that you
need to monitor a Redis instance as you
can see average commands per second the
95th percentile latency cash at ratio
etc are all available and these are
important metrics that you need to
determine how your instances functioning
if you want to see the full list of all
the metrics that are available just go
to metrics Explorer type in Redis and
you can see the full list of metrics
that are published in stackdriver
so as you can see with cloud memory
store creating managing and monitoring
Redis instance is actually very easy
so in short with cloud memory store you
don't have to worry about maintaining
your own VM to manage your reticence
instead you can simply click a few
buttons and then create manage and
monitor the instance
so in summary let's take a look at a
quick look at the offering with cloud
memory store you have a basic tier and a
standard tier and within the tiers you
also have memory tiers which gives you
different memory sizes with different
network performance as you can see the
m1 capacity tier gives you 3 gigabits
per second
m5 gives you about 12 gigabits per
second also with respect to pricing you
get a wide range of pricing options that
allows you to choose the right tier for
you so as you can see basic m1 is less
than five cents per gigabyte hour and
the standard instances are a little bit
more basic tier is ideal if you want to
have a low cost simple right as cash
[Music]